Afghanistan's Taliban rulers won't allow
women to join their cabinet but they
have no qualms meeting a woman cabinet
minister from another Islamic country
Pakistan's Deputy foreign minister Hina
rabbanihar was in Kabul earlier in the
week to meet her opposite number in the
Taliban the Taliban happy to greet her
at the airport and then sit across the
table from her an Afghan woman doing the
same would be Unthinkable among other
things Taliban rule has seen most Afghan
women prevented from going back to their
jobs and girls prevented from returning
to Secondary School
and that is something to discuss for
more I'm joining the studio by DW
reporter binesh Javed finish welcome in
her meeting with the Taliban did Deputy
foreign minister Hina rabbanikar bring
up the issue of the treatment of Afghan
women
um
Pakistan brought up the issue of women
rights in its negotiation with Taliban
and during her visit to Kabul in
arabanika also met with members of
Afghan women Chamber of Commerce and
Pakistan also stressed that it would
prefer doing business with Afghan women
entrepreneurs and I think the fact that
Pakistan sent a woman Minister instead
of foreign minister Bilal puto any other
male official also showed to the world
and also to Taliban that when a woman is
educated she has agency she has freedom
and she has she's empowered she can be
involved in the most important decision
making of the country and I think
Taliban the world also saw that Taliban
who has faster woman to cover themselves
from head to toe and are crushing their
rights here they are meeting a woman
Minister from neighboring Muslim country
not even a western or a European country
and Hillary Panic at is not only has not
if her head is also not properly covered
but they wouldn't allow an Afghan woman
in that position of command where she's
leading a delegation and talking eye to
eye and equally with Afghan Taliban
leadership so sending a message to the
Afghan Taliban leadership and therefore
the question how important is restoring
women's rights in Afghanistan for
Pakistan I mean it's important but I
don't think that it's a priority right
now for Pakistan uh Pakistan right now
is under threat from uh terrorism
activities of Pakistani Taliban it's a
group that has for years attacked
Pakistani State its people children and
since Afghan Taliban took over in
Afghanistan these attacks have increased
and Pakistan believes that Pakistani
Taliban and these militants are based in
Afghanistan and they are planning these
attacks from the Afghan territory and I
remember in August 2021 I was an
Islamabad
took over
um some military officials were very
jubilant and happy that now Pakistan
will have a friendly neighbor in its
western border and of course Pakistan
already has a hostile neighbor on its
eastern border but the reality has been
that western border has been uh has seen
a lot of problems and there have been
attacks on Pakistan territory I I think
number one message that henarabanikar
gave to Afghan Taliban was that they
want help of Afghan Taliban encountering
this threat of terrorism that Pakistan
believes is coming from the afghan's
wife aside from the foreign policy
deliberations I understand that you
yourself were in Kabul at the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs in 2012 what was it
like then yes so I was about part of an
journalism fellowship program and I
stayed in Kabul for 10 days and I
remember that at the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs we were welcomed by these young
women foreign Ministry officers and they
told us about what kind of Afghanistan
they want what kind of foreign policy
they were pursuing and what kind of
relations they want with Afghanistan I
also went to different other government
Ministries and to also to a news channel
told the news and there were women
participants there so women were very
active part of the society and that is
completely missing right now when I see
visuals of in arabanika meeting with
Afghan Taliban leadership and one thing
I'll quickly say I remember the story
um Afghan and Afghan journalists told me
that he his sister who's actually six
years older than him than him both of
them graduated at the same time because
from 1996 to 2001 when Afghanistan was
under Taliban control his sister
couldn't go to school and unfortunately
that is happening again men after so
many years with so many Afghan women
which is just disappointing and
extremely heartbreak indeed
thank you
and as binis just said the situation is
very different now women human rights
activists for instance have been
arrested and tortured activists such as
who spent 24 days in jail after being
arrested for participating in a women's
rights protest in Kabul in mid-January
this year she's now in Germany as a
refugee and spoke to DW news about her
experience in prison
do you know what punishment we have
chosen for you a Taliban member asked me
one day I said I didn't he said they
would Stone me tell the other girl to
pray we are going to Stone you he said I
started crying and asked him what my
crime was that was the worst time my
biggest wish was to get a helmet so that
I would not get hurt if they stoned me I
checked my clothes to see if there was
something that could protect me from
stoning and I wondered wood stoning hurt
a malformation
activist parwana nishrabi spent 24 days
in a Taliban prison in Afghanistan
her work fighting for women's rights put
her in the Hardline group's Firing Line
since seizing power in August 2021 the
Taliban have severely restricted these
rights
girls have been bought from school and
women face increasingly harsh social
restrictions
after protesting for women's rights in
the Afghan Capital Kabul nishrabi was
arrested
I don't know which Taliban member
slapped my face first
I felt my eardrums were damaged
and he slapped me again and my mouth
started bleeding
tried to get out of the car in which
they were carrying me
but another Taliban member who was
sitting in the back seat hit me in my
back with his pistol
Nish rabi says the Taliban tortured her
and forced her to sign a confession
document eventually releasing her the
activist recently arrived in Germany but
remains haunted by the inhumane
conditions she endured
the toilet was in the same room where
they kept me
the Taliban were watching me all the
time even when I was using the toilet
washing myself or just walking in the
room
I had to cover myself with a cloth while
using the toilet
I had no privacy
[Music]
is a former policy special advisor to
the UK Minister for Afghan resettlement
and Minister for refugees she joins me
now from London Ms dasimi why does the
Taliban need to torture women when
they've already curtailed their rights
I think one thing is very clear that the
people of Afghanistan and in particular
women are being denied their basic human
rights and the bottom line is the
Taliban have so clearly demonstrated
that they are not going to abide by any
agreement that they may have made with
the International Community over the
years
they seem to think of their legitimacy
in part in large part is on keeping
women out of sight and any kind of
public role they use fear and violence
as a means of controlling women and and
the country they have no legitimacy no
qualifications to govern a nation and it
is only through uh curtailing women's
rights and the rights of the people of
Afghanistan that they can control and
they believe they can control the nation
and and govern it and it is both
appalling and a dangerous sign the
Taliban are becoming more and more
defiant in showing the world that they
are embracing the policies of the past I
think
um you know it didn't end well for them
before and it will not end for them uh
well for them again now you used to
advise the UK government and policy in
Afghanistan and remain involved with the
country do you think that the
International Community is no longer as
committed to Afghanistan as it was say
even after until a year back
look I think it's it
fully is incredibly
heartbreaking to
how little coverage uh the situation of
women in Afghanistan is getting because
the future of Afghanistan is a stable
and a peaceful Nation just as any other
nation in the world depends on the
future of women's rights and 15 months
have already gone by where women have
been banned from from restricted from
working Young Girls teenage girls have
been banned from school it is the only
country in the world where young girls
are not allowed to receive an education
it is a shameful mark on on the
International Community on Humanity that
a country like that exists where human
rights are restricted for the basic
human rights for women so I think it is
definitely upsetting to see
um how little support the women of
Afghanistan are receiving from the
United International Community but it it
shows even more how desperately they
need our attention particularly the
Muslim majority countries you know the
West have been there for 20 years the
expectation is always there for them to
show their support but I think right now
because the Taliban Taliban are in power
Afghanistan is relying more on the
Muslim majority countries that are
neighbors to convey a very unified and
strong message about the cost of
stability and prosperity if half the
population isn't allowed to contribute
to society in Afghanistan very briefly
what does the future of women in
Afghanistan under Taliban rule look like
very Bleak very dark there is no future
for Afghanistan there is no future for a
growth in the economy in diminishing the
humanitarian crisis or any kind of
prosperity in a nation where like I said
half the population is restricted and
imprisoned at home currently the Taliban
have proven that they have no respect
for Humanity for the Dignity of the
people of Afghanistan and it is honestly
incredibly important that the global
Community come together now before it is
too late we leave it there for the time
thank you so much for joining us a
former policy special advisor to the UK
Minister for Afghan resettlement and
Minister for refugees thank you so much